mills who's tough as they come covers
his tour in afghanistan and life as a
quadruple amputee
that all happens tonight on c-span 2's
book tv
first up here's stephen kinzer
tonight we're lucky to host stephen
kinser who will be speaking on his
latest book just released on tuesday we
are also pleased that robin young the
co-host of here and now on wbur npr has
agreed to interview mr kinser
robin is a peabody awarding
award-winning documentary filmmaker who
was also reported for nbc cbs and abc
television and for several years was a
substitute host and correspondent for
the today show
robin has received several emory awards
for her television work as well as
cable's ace award and radio's regional
edward r murrow award
stephen kinser is an award-winning
foreign correspondent who has covered
more than 50 countries on five
continents his articles and books have
led the washington post to place him
among the best in popular foreign policy
storytelling
he spent more than 20 years working for
the new york times most of it as a
foreign correspondent
while covering events he has been shot
at
jailed beaten by the police tear-gassed
and bombed from the air and that was
prior to the current administration in
washington
so we're pleased to provide sanctuary
tonight
today stephen is a senior fellow at the
watson institute for international and
public affairs at brown university he
also writes a world affairs column for
the boston globe
robin and stephen will discuss we'll be
discussing steven's new book as i
mentioned the true flag in which he
explores the history of the united
states role on the world stage
a subject that seems strikingly
important
he focuses on the dawn of the 20th
century when the united states first
found itself with a chance to dominate
far away lands
that prospect thrilled some americans it
horrified others
the debate involved some of the most
influential minds of the time including
theo roosevelt
and henry cabot lodge his papers by the
way are here at the society and if you
haven't seen the little exhibition that
peter drummy did in the hallway make
sure you see it on your way out letters
between roosevelt and lodge and william
randolph hearst on one side and mark
twain booker t washington and andrew
carnegie arguing alternate perspectives
the debate gripped the nation
and hopefully it will shed some light on
the condition of america today it is my
pleasure to welcome stephen and robin
thank you
thank you so much
um i just have to say this book was
thrilling to read and here's an example
of why i often try to highlight what i
think are the you know the moments that
i want to remember i went through two
highlighters on this book it is so
thrilling it's thrilling to uh as we
just heard
hear of our past history reflected in
our our current time it was also uh
dispiriting in many ways which we'll get
to including um my real name is young's
with an s and got lost years ago um but
uh it was so kind of dispiriting to read
what a jerk teddy roosevelt was
he is buried in my family cemetery the
young cemetery in oyster bay and we
always were very proud of that until i
got like halfway through this book
so let's get right to it a thrilling
contemporary but history and a part of
history i don't think many people know
about it so we just heard who the
players were you've got
teddy roosevelt henry cabot lodge would
you click richard kipling and william
randolph hearst on the other side mark
twain william jennings brian booker t
washington and andrew carnegie arguing
set the scene for us stephen late 1800s
what was going on in the world spain
had colonized cuba what was going on
all of my book projects are really
efforts at trying to uncover untold
stories i'm looking for stories that
were hugely important in history but
that for some reason have just been
forgotten
so
as you point out 1898 was a moment of
great change in the united states it was
the year when we decided that filling up
north america was not enough and we were
going to continue expanding and
jump from being a continental empire to
being an overseas empire so that story's
been told many times and that's a story
with which i've been quite familiar
but what i had never realized and this
is the main discovery that led me to
write this book
is that this was not an automatic or an
easy decision
as a matter of fact the united states
was caught up in a huge national debate
over whether this was the right thing to
do or not
all of the arguments that we made about
whether or not to get into vietnam or
central america or the middle east all
originally were made at this time so
the united states signed a treaty with
spain under which we took control of
former spanish colonies and that treaty
had to be ratified by the us senate
the battle over that ratification
riveted the entire nation the senate met
for 32 days to debate this treaty every
major political and intellectual figure
in america took sides
but we've more or less forgotten this
debate as a matter of fact the decision
to pursue this course to begin pushing
american military and strategic power
around the world
was very narrowly taken the senate vote
to ratify that treaty of paris
was carried by one vote more than the
required two-thirds and then the supreme
court had to rule on whether it was
constitutional for americans to rule
other countries and not give them any
rights you not give the people there any
rights and they ruled that it was okay
by a five to four vote
so
one of the things that i'm trying to
point out in this book is that those of
us who question
this idea that the united states is the
indispensable nation and has to push
itself into every conflict in the world
are not coming up with these ideas new
in fact
the debate is over a hundred years old
this in the history of american foreign
policy is truly the mother of all
debates
the only difference between that one and
this one is not the themes it's how
articulate they were the the senators on
both sides are so sophisticated they're
talking about the cataline conspiracy of
pliny the elder in ways that you'd never
expect to hear a senator speak today
well let's talk a little bit more about
that um especially since you have people
like well mark twain was a little off
the stage in the beginning of your story
he enters the stage at the end but you
have the expansionists um who were
i mean it's amazing to read this now
it's wince inducing they were talking
about how uh it was sort of the white
man's burden you have rigid kipling's um
poem to that effect
because these countries that they were
thinking of were mainly people of color
savages and when the uh
anti-imperialists who were based here in
boston they had a big rally at daniel
hall when they argued what are you
talking about we have a constitution
that's of the people by the people
government of the people by the people
people like roosevelt and lodge said oh
no that's white people
but they really said that
exactly the argument that
the anti-imperialists made was
essentially as you point out our country
was founded as a rebellion against
foreign domination the constitution
begins with the words we the people
we are dedicated to the principle that
all legitimate government derives its
legitimacy from the consent of the
governed abraham lincoln talked about
government of by and for the people so
how can we now go and impose our will on
others i'm going to quote uh george
frisbie [ __ ] one of the massachusetts
senators who was strongly on the
anti-imperialist side he said you have
no right at the cannon's mouth to impose
on an unwilling people your declaration
of independence and your constitution
and your notions of freedom and notions
of what is good
the other republican senator from
massachusetts henry cavett lodge had an
answer that is also the kind of rhetoric
we still hear
i do not believe that this nation was
raised up for nothing i have faith that
it has a great mission in the world a
mission of good
a mission of freedom
it takes us to george h.w bush who at
the end of the cold war said that the
united states had to dominate the new
world order because it was up to us to
do the hard work of freedom so the terms
of this debate are really all repetitive
and they all find their roots in this
original conflict that shook the u.s in
1898 to 1900s well and it included the
philippines i want you to lay out that
chronology for us but
rudyard kipling in writing the white
man's bird in the united states and the
philippine islands if i may he writes
yes sorry i have to lean over this way
he writes take up the white man's burden
send forth the best ye breed go bind
your sons to exile to serve your
captives need to wait in heavy harnessed
on fluttered folk and wild your new
caught sullen peoples half devil and
half child speaking of the filipinos and
this is what somebody wrote in the
newspaper kind of in response to that an
anti-imperialist we've taken up the
white man's burden of ebony and brown
now will you tell us rudyard how may we
put it down
so this is the this is the way they
discussed this
both in the newspapers william randolph
hearst newspapers in particular but take
us through the chronology there was war
in cuba even after the treaty so take us
through that what happened was that
cuban rebels were fighting at the last
stage of their war to overthrow spanish
rule
as that battle that war reached a peak
william randolph hearst in desperate
search for circulation began a wild
campaign about atrocities in cuba it's
actually another trope that we still go
through americans are very compassionate
people we hate the idea that anybody's
suffering anywhere and whenever any of
our leaders want to
intervene or in or invade or crash into
another country somewhere they always
cloak it in this humanitarian garb so
we're always looking for poor people
that have been brutalized and suffered
during and are tortured and so forth so
hearst gave us a steady diet of that
including graphic stories of people that
were actually dying and holding pens
while the reporters watched later on to
be turned out that the reporters had
never even been in cuba
and hearst also played a huge role in
whipping up american sentiment by
falsely reporting that the uss maine our
worship in havana harbor had been blown
up by the spanish
and even published a diagram on the
front page of his newspaper showing how
the mine had been attached to a
detonator on land actually 70 years
later the navy convened a review
committee to find out it was only an
accident there was no detonator there
was no mine
but whipped up into this fervor the
americans decided we're going to send
troops to cuba and we're going to help
those cuban rebels overthrow the brutal
spanish the cuban rebels were not so
sure they wanted this
they feared what the americans would do
once they were in cuba so the u.s
congress passed a law
the teller amendment
promising that as soon as the spanish
were overthrown in cuba
we would allow cuba to become fully
independent with that assurance the
cubans welcomed american troops teddy
roosevelt had his famous day on san juan
hill which he decided qualified him for
the medal of honor
and the americans easily defeated the
spanish in cuba at the same time the
spanish fleet happened to be parked in
the philippines an island most americans
had never heard of
and
an american fleet went to destroy the
spanish fleet then suddenly we found
ourselves in possession of the
philippines
didn't know what to do with it
but suddenly a president mckinley after
getting down on his knees and having a
religious vision in the white house at
night
said that he had been told by god that
it was his duty to go to the philippines
take them over and christianize the
people there
um
apparently he wasn't clear that they
most were at least catholic already
after several centuries of spanish rule
but god at that time sounded very much
like henry cabot lodge and theodore
roosevelt
that became then the crux of our debate
so we signed a treaty with spain and we
forced the spanish to surrender all
these islands the philippines guam
cuba and puerto rico
and we paid 20 million dollars for for
the philippines
andrew carnegie immediately announced he
wants to pay the u.s treasury 20 million
dollars to buy the philippines so he can
set them free
carnegie wrote this fierce essay saying
how can we hang the declaration of
independence on the wall in schoolhouses
in the philippines when we have made it
illegal in the philippines to advocate
filipino independents
so a huge war broke out in the
philippines and i think only the
anti-imperialists had expected this
mckinley and roosevelt and lodge i think
and the others believed that the
filipinos would simply accept this so
for the first time in our history
the united states wound up in a war in
which we had to shoot down
people who legitimately felt that they
were fighting for their own independence
hundreds of thousands of people were
killed in that war
we've largely forgotten in fact i think
we've entirely forgotten it but it was a
huge
moment in u.s asia relations and it
really reflects right up into the
present day because
some of you may have noticed just a
month or two ago the president of the
philippines made this startling
announcement that he doesn't want to be
friends with the united states anymore
but what was hardly reported in the
press was that as he made this
announcement at a press conference he
was holding up a photograph
of u.s marines standing over a pit full
of dead filipino civilians more than a
hundred years ago and that's the reason
he said why we're still angry at the u.s
so it shows you that
while we forget these interventions
they fester and burn in the minds and
hearts and souls of people in other
countries and the blowback ultimately
reaches us well
when you think of teddy roosevelt's
incursions in cuba i mean it's almost
comical this idea that he would say i
want to kill someone he was so excited
about killing someone it'd be jolly and
and some of the reporters that uh went
with him who'd never been at war and
hurst and it's almost comical by the
time we get to the end of your telling
and what happened in the philippines it
is it's heartbreaking i mean it's it's
uh u.s troops burning villages murdering
civil murdering civilians
performing water torture
waterboarding something the spaniards
had done and i love your quote from um
mark twain saying wait what what do you
water torture torture to do what
they won't tell you the truth if
somebody is water tortured they're going
to say whatever
you want them to say it was just
chilling to hear him saying that 100
years ago but before but before this
thing is in my way can you tell but
before we get to the end of the story
and
what happened go back a ways to teddy
roosevelt you know wanting to kill a
buffalo wanting to kill someone at war
stay with roosevelt for a while
so really i do use theodore roosevelt
and mark twain as the main figures in
this conflict roosevelt as the epitome
of the imperialist the expansionist and
mark twain as the bitter
anti-imperialists
so
roosevelt uh grew up in a very sheltered
environment he had really never gone to
a classroom until he got to harvard um
he was fascinated by
war the navy ships um
always wanted to get himself into some
kind of combat he believed that war was
really the only
noble
pursuit for a man and that others and
that who those who pursued peace were
just blubbery jellyfish who had no idea
of the vigor of what life really was
roosevelt was also a little bit
humiliated by the fact that his father
had paid a substitute to fight in the
civil war so he wanted to redeem the
family honor
he was desperate to kill someone in the
spanish-american war and he finally did
manage to do it later on when he sent
his sons off to world war one we have a
letter in which he says i hope they come
back missing a few legs and arms between
them so he really was a person that had
a fascination with war
um mark twain was exactly the opposite
so twain had traveled the world he had
been in places where
europeans were brutalizing local
citizens from south africa to the south
pacific islands um
and he became a
bitter anti-imperialist this was
actually my second biggest discovery in
writing this book the first discovery
was that this debate ever happened what
a huge story that we've never been told
but my second biggest discovery was
figuring out that mark twain
was not the person that i'd been brought
up to know about he wasn't just the
gentle wisecracking grandpa who
everybody loved he was vituperative
in his
anti-imperialism he wrote that theodore
roosevelt was clearly insane
and undoubtedly the worst president we
have ever had
and uh roosevelt returned the compliment
by saying he would like to skin mark
twain alive
i'm at that page right now and
before this hey actually twain said that
uh uh roosevelt was the most formidable
disaster that's befallen the country
since the civil war um and roosevelt
when he was talking to kipling about
these
anti-imperialists like mark twain i mean
the racism is pretty astonishing
he said for instance these jack fools
who seriously think that any group of
pirates and headhunters needs nothing
but independence in order that it be
turned forth with into a dark hued new
england town meeting
i mean they were completely dismissive
of the anti-imperialists
um and mark twain as you said just you
know rabid uh
about the expansionists
but
we're missing one piece here of why uh
there was the expansionist movement it
had to do with the fact that the u.s was
so productive at the time american
workers were making so many things
they'd run out of americans to sell them
to
and roosevelt and lodge in particular
were very clear we need to take other
countries so that we can subdue them
civilize them and then sell them things
absolutely
i did a lot of research
in old magazines and newspapers so i
could understand what was being
discussed at this time
one of the themes that constantly comes
forth is what was in those days called
glut
so
american manufacturers and american
farmers had so completely mastered
techniques of mass production that they
were producing far more than americans
could consume and this was producing
trouble in america that's when he
started having these great labor strikes
and pinkertons were shooting down
strikers in various parts of the country
we felt that there might be serious
upheaval coming in the united states the
solution was to take foreign countries
and you could not export to europe
because europe was protected by tariff
walls and european colonies were
protected they were those colonies
existed
to give exclusive trade to their mother
country so our idea was if we could take
hawaii that would be a great step to the
philippines if we could take the
philippines that could be a big market
but most important and this is a big
theme in the newspapers of the time it
could be a springboard to the china
market that was vast and there's article
after article
speculating on what it could mean to
american industry and to american
workers if the chinese could be made for
example to eat beef instead of
vegetables and rice if they could use
cotton how much cotton could all of
china consume what if they started to
use metal nails to build their houses
how many nails could we export there so
the uh
specter of these giant new markets not
to mention the resources that we would
come out of them as one senator came
home with a big glistening nugget of
gold from the philippines to show what
we could get were definitely very
important factors in enticing us into
this new imperial career well but then
it starts to unravel in different ways
um the us conquers cuba
not a big uh accomplishment truly at
that time this small group of uh rebels
we had actually a point as i pointed out
we had promised not to do that in the
teller amendment and then came this big
question well we're not going to let
cuba become independent because we've
discovered that the rebels there want to
limit the amount of foreign goods that
can be sold in cuba they want to take
over the giant plantations and cut them
up and give the land to peasants so we
can't keep the promise that we made and
so we finally passed another law the
plat amendment in which we said well
we'll give you independence but only
under the condition that the u.s will be
able to veto everything you do so that
became the new paradigm by which we
ruled cuba and other latin americans
well the other thing that happened is
that roosevelt and others who went and
had this big woohoo um fight
found out that
many cubans are black
and they recoiled from that wait a
second we don't want black people to be
part of the united states and
despoiling white america absolutely uh
this was one of the great shocks that we
learned
when we read the william randolph hearst
stories about the valiant cuban rebels
everybody in america loved them they
were heroes then the soldiers got there
and they found out that these people
were mostly black
and therefore immediately they were all
assigned to just do the ditch digging
and carry the uh
supplies for the american soldiers and
naturally they didn't react so well to
that um we also have a lot of reports
from the americans saying that the
cubans didn't seem grateful to us
why weren't they so grateful to us for
coming in and saving them not realizing
that they had been at war for years that
had not been in the american press and
we just got down there a few weeks
earlier so uh you can actually trace
some of the photos for example of one of
the black commanders of the cuban rebels
antonio maseo
at the beginning when he was first
pictured in the u.s
he was pictured as he was black but as
the war proceeded he got lighter and
lighter so that we would see this is the
guy we should support
so it really is true that the shock of
learning that black people would be
involved in government in cuba if we
allowed cuban independence was one
reason we decided cuba can absolutely
not become independent it's as you said
earlier we had this view
that uh
as one senator said in his speech on
this treaty of paris the opposition
tells us that we ought not to govern a
people without their consent
i answer the rule of liberty that all
just government derives its authority
from the consent of the government
applies only to those who are capable of
self-government we govern our children
without their consent
this is the same attitude we took
towards people that were not white
that's the real under text here and it's
not very deep below the surface white
people are capable of governing
themselves dark-skinned people are not
and therefore we have to go in even
though they're not asking us and
president mckinley
had to square this odd circle how can
americans justify
doing this in the philippines and he
came to boston to make the speech at
mechanics hall right where the
prudential center now is was the biggest
banquet ever staged in the history of
the united states over two thousand
people served in there and at that
speech mckinley had a great line which
you could hear again today
he said
about the filipinos now did we need
their consent to perform a great act for
humanity we had it in every aspiration
of their minds in every hope of their
hearts
so here he's saying that the people who
most need to be dominated by the united
states are the ones who are so backward
that they don't even realize they need
our help
and enter booker t washington
now he steps to the podium at some of
these rallies and says what
booker t washington was the leading
african-american figure during that era
and of course he was focused on the
struggle of colored people inside the
united states but as you see from
reading african-american newspapers
during that era they had a great
interest in what was happening in cuba
and the philippines and a great sympathy
for the natives there much more so than
the mainstream american press so booker
t washington actually stood up at a
speech when mckinley was giving a big
address in chicago
and pointed out that he there was as he
put it a cancer growing in american
society and that
as long as we were oppressing people in
other countries
we would then view with apathy the idea
of doing that here at home
it bears note
that the
judge on the supreme court who wrote the
decision
saying that it was constitutional for
americans to rule people in other lands
without giving them rights
also voted for the decision in which the
united states supreme court certified
segregation as legal
so it made sense actually there's a
connection what in both cases you're
saying that not everybody under american
rule deserves the same rights as white
people
roosevelt
he makes his way to secretary of the
navy with the help of lodge
it's amazing to see how
they
sort of blatantly maneuver their way
up to the vice presidency
so now you have roosevelt as vice
president you have mark twain returning
from overseas he'd originally supported
as many had the
war in cuba because again he thought
this was liberating people and he
quickly realized what was going on
you have mark twain
taking on roosevelt and president
mckinley
and others
at banquets where sometimes roosevelt
was in attendance describe that scene
it's really quite remarkable uh
mark twain was really feisty and i i now
see him as a
very serious thinker on great global
political issues not not just a gentle
humorist so
he did give a speech
in which he addressed theodore roosevelt
directly he gave a speech in which
winston churchill was present and he
admonished winston churchill he actually
said thank you for pointing out that the
united states and britain
are brothers
i would admit that what we're doing in
the philippines is like what you're
doing in south africa so sure we are kin
in sin
later on mark twain published some
vituperative pieces including one which
to me reads almost like an obituary for
the united states after the congress
does decide to go ahead on this imperial
path
i think if you could write this today
it was impossible to save the great
republic she was rotten to the heart
lust of conquest had long ago
done its work the government was
irrevocably in the hands of the
prodigiously rich and their hangers on
the suffrage was become a mere machine
which they used as they chose there was
no principle but commercialism
no patriotism but of the pocket
he's lamenting the situation a hundred
years ago and uh sounds like we haven't
come too far
well here is a bit of mark twain when he
realizes that roosevelt is
here's a bit of mark twain when he
realizes that roosevelt is right in the
room with him he's speaking at another
kind of banquet toastmaster at a dinner
and he
points out roosevelt and he says he
hadn't anything personal against me
except that i was opposed to the
political war he said i was a traitor
and didn't go to fight in the
philippines that doesn't prove anything
that doesn't prove a man as a traitor it
would be an entirely different question
if the country's life was in danger its
existence at stake
then that's one kind of patriotism we'd
all come forward and stand by the flag
and stop thinking about whether the
nation was right or wrong but when
there's no question that the nation is
in any way in danger but only some
little war a way off that it may be that
of the question of politics the nation
is divided i'm trying to picture that
room i'm trying to picture the squirming
in the seats as he said that to
roosevelt people were very unhappy with
his first public speech at his favorite
club in new york when he came back from
uh europe was one in which he said
we have sent our soldiers out to do a
bandit's work under a polluted flag
and the good citizens of new york who
were in the audience were very unhappy
about that they were jumping up and
saying we are sending our soldiers out
under a noble flag not a polluted flag
and rose and twain just sat and smiled
and didn't reply but uh
the uh intensity of
uh reaction that he drew uh was
something of which he was very aware and
it only intensified uh his own desire to
sharpen his rhetorical knife
what was happening in america as this
war in the philippines started to go
very very badly i think at one point you
say
you have one of the characters saying
more have been killed in the philippines
than in six revolutions
the war in the philippines did not turn
out the way americans thought it would
we thought
excuse me if you're uh
comparing this to anything else we
thought they would greet us with flowers
we thought it would be over in a few
weeks we would just get rid of the tiny
elite of bad people and the natural
pro-american-ness of the locals would
flower and they would love us and be
grateful in fact the opposite happened a
full-scale rebellion broke out in the
philippines
and
at this time
opposition to the war and the
expansionist project was being led by an
organization that was hugely active and
well known in the united states then but
that we've completely forgotten and that
was the anti-imperialist league
all these people like carnegie and jane
adams and
booker t washington and samuel gompers
were all vice presidents very active
leaders in the anti-imperialist league
and the league was promoting uh
opposition to the war by sending out
leaflets that were produced here in
boston uh by lobbying by uh organizing
public meetings several of which were
held here at faneuil hall and the
tremont temple
so uh
the philippines war
gripped america because it was something
so new for us we had never fought a
foreign guerrilla war
nor had we ever been in the position of
having to do terrible things this was
our first torture scandal
the scandal over what was called the
water cure later to be known uh by
another name at guantanamo
was really the beginning of a loss of
innocence for the united states i think
it was the philippine war that led
americans to realize
there's a bad world out there and if we
are going to go out and project our
power we're going to have to do bad
things like other countries do
uh that's a realization that i think
we're still grappling with the american
soul is quite divided you know we are
imperialists but we're also
isolationists we really want to guide
the world but we want every country to
guide itself and that divided soul is
something you see coming right out of
this original debate of 1898 or you
could take it even back further to 1630
with john winthrop what did he mean
when he said
we shall be as a city upon a hill in the
eyes of all people are upon us so did he
mean
we should go out in the world and redeem
it and make it better or did he mean no
we should create a virtuous society at
home and see if it could become a model
to others we still haven't decided that
and that shapes our divided approach to
the world right up to this day well
meantime
i just want to put a little capper on on
the story
in 1901 president mckinley is
assassinated vice president roosevelt
becomes president as you've said people
americans are seeing i mean how many
troops american troops there 80 000 000.
80 000 almost 100 000 american troops
are there
more and more people are becoming aware
of that it's just not going well at all
and then after the war it almost feels
as if roosevelt
wants to draw attention away from the
failures there by scapegoating the
military who carried the war out
there was an investigation uh after uh
roosevelt was president into torture and
other abuses in the philippines henry
cavett lodge a great supporter of the
war maneuvered to become the uh chairman
of that investigating committee that
made sure that it was never going to
come up with a report or find out
anything that was negative
on the other hand
there was
a great sense in the united states
that
this had not gone well and president
roosevelt did something that i think
people had not expected he was the most
rabid of nation grabbers and once he was
in power without any anyone like
mckinley to restrain him
woe to any nation on which the united
states had ever cast a covetous eye
but he didn't do that he didn't he could
have gone ahead and next nicaragua
guatemala parts of mexico parts of
africa parts of china all of this was in
the air but he didn't
he began to realize the sorrows of
empire and the troubles that it brings
and i think that's a pattern for
presidents right up to obama they come
into office very excited about the idea
of using american military power to work
our will in the world but as they sit in
office for a while and they see
the ill effects of those interventions
not only on the target country but on
the united states itself they cool off
quite a bit i think that's a logical
process one could only wish that they
would learn the lesson before they get
in and not have to take several years in
power before they cooled off well just
to give your example of what americans
heard in that scapegoating if it was but
um
what they heard and how shocking it was
there was a major anthony waller who was
being questioned during this
investigation into what happened here
and of course we know what happened it
was completely um navigated by the or or
carried out by the expansionists
and this major said that uh he was in a
reprisal campaign in samar and a general
smith gave him extermination orders
i want no prisoners smith told him i
wish you to kill and burn the more you
kill and burn the better you will please
me i want all persons killed who are
capable of bearing arms and so the major
asphalt for an age guideline
and the general said to him ten years
persons 10 years and over are those
designated as being able to bear arms
yes
and then the major went on to say he was
ordered to make it a howling wilderness
and his men complied raising every
village and massacring the
civilians how did that hit at home
as i say i think it was a loss of
innocence for americans we began to
think well we've now entered into this
new career and these are the things we
have to do on the other hand
i believe the anti-imperialists also
uh had success even though they didn't
have the ultimate success
it was their work that i think led
roosevelt to realize slowly many
americans are turning against this
enterprise so i think that
the shock
of realizing what americans had had to
do in the philippines helped assure that
this last burst of annexation
would be this first burst of annexation
would be the last now we continue to
intervene in countries in other ways but
we didn't go ahead and seize them as
colonies the way we did with the
philippines and puerto rico and guam so
the
anti-imperialists always wound up losing
in the end the great battles but it they
have still been a major force in
american politics you can trace them up
right through
liberal democrats like george mcgovern
and conservative republicans like ron
paul they're all advocating this same
view one difference though and this is a
little bit depressing when you think
about what's happened over these hundred
years is this
in the period that i write about in the
true flag
so 1898 to 1900
the american elites the the prominent
figures in america were deeply divided
over the question of whether it's a good
idea for the u.s to project its coercive
power around the world or that's a bad
idea
now
you don't see that division
in washington it's all monochromatic the
idea that the us is the indispensable
nation that we have to be involved in
every conflict in the world that we're
where we are present there becomes peace
and security where we are absent there
is darkness and everyone lives in chains
this view is shared widely in washington
uh american
influence is always benign everybody is
waiting for our help we can make
situations better
this is a view that is shared by
democrats and republicans you won't find
so much difference between the view of a
john mccain and a hillary clinton for
example on these issues liberals and
conservatives pretty much share these
assumptions
every think tank in washington with very
few exceptions shares them and the media
i'm sorry to say is also beating these
drums so
one thing we've lost uh from the period
of more than a hundred years ago is this
great debate among our leading figures
in fact all of our leading political and
intellectual figures with very few
exceptions tend to be on the side that
believes america really is the
indispensable nation and if if we are
not involved everywhere in the world the
world will go crazy we'll have disasters
we are the only force standing between
the world and chaos
so that's a widely shared view now and
this view that i mentioned earlier of
george frisbie [ __ ] uh you have no
right at the cannon's mouth to do this
is not widely
shared
and actually it's from that perspective
that i took the title of my book this
was the if the big discovery of my book
was that this debate happened and the
second was what the real mark twain the
third interesting discovery for me was a
guy that i had never heard of carl
schurtz who was one of the most
fascinating immigrants to the united
states during the 19th century came from
germany where he had fought in the 1848
revolutions he became a civil war
general he was a u.s senator first u.s
senator from born of germany he was
secretary of the interior
very popular famous figure would have
been known to all americans at the in
the latter part of the 19th century
and so my book the true flag
takes uh that title from a line that
carl shorts delivered at a speech at the
university of chicago
let us raise high the flag of our
country
not as an emblem of reckless adventure
and greedy conquest
of betrayed professions and broken
pledges of criminal aggressions and
arbitrary rule over subject populations
but the old
the true flag
the flag of george washington and
abraham lincoln the flag of the
government of for and by the people
the flag of national faith held sacred
and of national honor unsullied the flag
of human rights and of good example to
all nations the flag of true
civilization peace and goodwill to all
men
that's the view that is rarely expressed
in the corridors of power in the united
states and part of the purpose of my
book is to recover the richness
of that dialogue so that we can use it
as a basis on which to make our
arguments today
how interesting those words were spoken
by an immigrant
stephen kinser
stephen kinser
i can tell you
i loved this book so much we could go on
there's so much more to talk about but i
i know we want to get some questions in
in the time that we have we have you
know c-span here so we're kind of and by
the way let's let's really you know
you know rock it for that state
organization let's do something crazy
here because we got c-span um so we want
if you have questions for stephen kinser
please come up and feel free to ask them
go ahead mr cancer what is your um
what is your feeling about theodore
roosevelt's role in the building of the
panama canal
so
teddy roosevelt's role in the building
of the canal
well
theodore roosevelt of course was
fascinated by sea power and the idea of
a canal through panama had been around
for centuries
so
roosevelt came into office determined to
build it immediately there wasn't going
to be any more delay at that time as you
all know the canal was supposed to be
built
across nicaragua there was a great
lobbying campaign it was quickly moved
to panama for very complicated and
mostly corrupt reasons panama was then a
province of colombia it was not an
independent country so we were roosevelt
was dealing with colombia but uh he
wasn't getting the deal that he wanted
um
so
he decided as he wrote to his secretary
of state john hay we have two
alternatives
um either to go back to the nicaragua
room
or
to stop dealing with the homicidal
corruptionists
in bogota and foment some kind of a
rebellion in the panama territory so
that's what he did
he arranged with a group of panamanians
to proclaim their province independent
of colombia and then he sent american
naval ships to blockade panama so that
the colombian navy could not show up
there and crush the rebellion we
immediately recognized the new
government and surprise the new
government's first act was to grant us
control over a big strip across their
country
so uh
afterward theodore roosevelt was
nervous that he was going to be accused
of
what he had actually done which is
essentially robbing breaking a nation in
half
and at a cabinet meeting he turned to
his attorney general
and he said
do they have any case against me can
they accuse me of anything and
the attorney general said
mr president let us not allow such a
great act to be tainted by any shadow of
legality
um first you've convinced me to buy your
book which
is a good thing
um
it's even better for me yes a lot of the
histories that i've read recently have
uh the thing that strikes me the most is
that the
purpose of writing the book is not so
much to tell the history
but to tell us something about today
and to give a couple of examples
[Music]
the recent book called black earth about
the holocaust is as much about
today and the future environmental
disasters as it is about
the 1930s
and 40s and um uh willie dalrymple's
book about the afghan wars
same thing um are you in that
esteemed group or
do you just enjoy bringing
um
obscure facts back to life
um
i do bring obscure facts back to life
but i think they're fascinating facts
just because they're obscure doesn't
mean they're not interesting
i've often
reflected on how it is that certain
episodes become considered very big and
important and get whole chapters in
history books and other episodes just
get one line as a footnote
why does this happen
i think to a certain degree when it
comes to our interventions abroad
we highlight the few that come out
really well for example there's never an
end to the world war ii stories and
books and movies was it a huge event of
course did it shape the modern world yes
but also i think it has an appeal to us
because
world war ii shows us the way we want to
think that we are
we went into our countries countries
that were being brutally ruled by evil
tyrants we helped defeat them and then
we left democracy behind so we love that
story
but in many other stories
we don't come out so well we charge into
countries that morality is relatively
stable relatively democratic we leave
them in war and tyranny
that's not who we think we are so rather
than confront the reality of what that
implies and what that means for our
policies we rather just forget that
those episodes ever happened
so to your question am i writing only
about history or for today
i really think that the episode i'm
writing about this huge national debate
that erupted over whether we should
become a global coercive power or not is
hugely relevant to today it has never
been resolved
so i'm trying to point out that this
argument
is really as one senator put it the
greatest question that has ever been
presented to the american people
i think you could argue
that it was even a bigger question than
slavery because slavery only applied to
what was going to happen inside the
united states
this decision
had shattering impact for people all
over the world
so uh i have tried to speak to today in
two ways in this book first of all i
think the story itself will lead people
to
realize certain arguments that were made
then that are still very powerful in our
discourse on both sides today uh and the
other thing i've done is that i have
added a chapter on the end of the book
uh to bring it up to the modern age so
the story ends around 1902 or something
like that but what happened to the
debate did it just end no it actually
proceeded up to the modern day so my
last chapter does take us through the
presidents that have happened since
teddy roosevelt and show how the
pendulum has swung back and forth
between uh the more interventionists and
the less interventionists and the one
who the president who winds up being the
most anti-imperialist in american
history is one you wouldn't expect and
since you've already decided you're
going to buy the book i'm going to let
you go down and find out who it is
while someone else comes up you know i'm
thinking about what you're saying though
and i'm thinking that it is still
as gut-wrenching a conversation look at
syria you know the people who said we
have to go in and and help and this is
intervention as opposed to expansionism
but you know we why aren't we going in
and helping and yet actually the same
issue absolutely right so people are
suffering there shouldn't we go in this
is the way we're deciding if there's
more suffering there's more reason for
us to go in we don't stop to ask
ourselves what's the prospect that us
going in is actually going to make the
situation better
that's a much deeper question and a much
more difficult one to answer we just
assume that where we are things will get
better but if you ask the people of
libya or the people of iraq or the
people of many other countries they'll
tell you otherwise and that should
inform our decision making
uh we have another voice in the
wilderness locally speaking out against
the american exceptionalism point of
view that's andrew basovich and uh you
mentioned john winthrop's city on a hill
earlier and basevich likes to point out
that it wasn't an unconditional
statement in his sermon in 1630 what he
wrote was
that
we have made a covenant with god and if
we live up to that covenant we shall be
like a city in the hill
but if we do not we will be cursed our
name will be cursed by future
generations
was that perspective still around in the
late 19th 19th century or that long been
forgotten absolutely i think that piece
of the john winthrop message was still
there
it's not an accident that many of the
leaders of the anti-imperialist movement
were clergy others were abolitionists
they considered the anti-imperialist
movement to be just the logical next
step
from
abolitionism because if you believed it
was wrong to own another human being and
make him work without his consent then
it would certainly be wrong to own whole
nations full of people and and make them
feel that way uh
so i i'm a great admirer of basebitch
there are a few others of us out here
beating our spoons on the high chair
um
but this idea
that you point out uh
of a kind of religious based
sense that america has a mission in the
world and it's not to become another
oppressor among oppressors shows up in
george washington's great farewell
address he lists all the things that he
hopes we won't do all of which we've
gone ahead and done
and at the end he says that he realizes
americans are not going to listen to him
and then he says however he's got one
principle that he says he hopes would
prevent us from running the course which
has hitherto
marked the destiny of nations give to
mankind
the magnanimous and two novel example
of a people always guided
by an exalted justice and benevolence
can it be that providence has not
connected the felicity of a nation
with its virtue
it's reflecting on quotes like that that
have led me to come here tonight wearing
my george washington socks
another question are coming up come on
up and i want to say for those who might
not know andy basivich she's a professor
now at boston university served in the
military military analyst and was
against the war in iraq i think people
always say that no one was against the
war iraq he was against the war in iraq
before his own son was killed there so
he's he's quite a figure yeah hi i
wonder if you could just say something
about why these events began to happen
when they did uh what was the the the
role of american manufacturing
capability and i'm particularly
interested when uh it was mentioned that
andrew carnegie was an
anti-interventionist given that he was a
huge titan of industry thank you
so why did these events begin happening
when they did
i think a confluence of factors was at
work uh certainly there had been
pressure from manufacturers to find new
markets but also
the business elite was worried about
going to war they were worried about
instability so that wasn't the real
pressure you had a psychic pressure from
people like henry cavett lodge who truly
believed that european powers were
taking all the
good parts of the world and the united
states had to become involved in this
competition um
it was as if in his mind we would become
simply conscientious objectors and just
uh retire from the world and be safe
within our own country this was
something that was
fundamentally
alien to the natures of people like
roosevelt and lodge
like many americans they were compulsive
activists they wanted to be out there
making changes they they couldn't bear
the idea of history taking its own
course and i think they they do reflect
america in that sense
americans don't like to understand
things we like to do things and the
compulsive activism of this group of
people i think really was a factor now
without the
megaphone that william randolph hearst
provided
the nation would not have been whipped
up into this fervor of uh what we now
call fake news but this happened again i
mean in vietnam we went to war in part
based on an incident that we now know
never happened uh same thing happened in
iraq with weapons of mass destruction
as for andrew carnegie he really was a
fascinating figure uh
i love this line that he writes in his
uh famous article
tires the republic so soon of its
mission
he was an immigrant also and a great
believer that european powers had been
brought down by their overweening
ambition that's what brought down the
austro-hungarian empire and the russian
empire and the ottoman empire all the
way back to rome
so what you are looking for to in a
successful country as carnegie would see
it is one that was satisfied within its
own borders and did not try to subject
other peoples so he believed that he was
watching the beginning of the end
of america as he knew and knew it and
wanted it to be don't forget that this
time
carnegie was entering into the later
phase of his life he became a great
philanthropist he was that was when he
started founding things like
the international court of justice in
the hague he was involved in other
international peace projects so this was
the beginning of a new stage in his
career
he had a great affection for mark twain
and
when twain published one of his bitter
denunciations of imperialism
carnegie wrote to him and said he he
wanted to pay the anti-imperialist
league to make this into a pamphlet and
send it out and he wrote to twain and
said
this is
the a better gospel of saint mark than i
even read in the bible
there's more carnegie endowment at that
at that point and i just want to mention
that it's a good thing that this fervor
abated because they had their eye on
canada
also and hawaii
absolutely although
looking back on it i sometimes wonder
look at canada's success look at all the
trouble the united states has had and if
our wars had gone differently how
different our country might have been
suppose we'd won the war of 1812 that
would have meant we would have kicked
the british out of north america
altogether and canada and the u.s would
have been one country then what if we'd
lost the civil war
then it would just have been new england
and the northern states and canada that
would have been a quite an interesting
country quite different from the one we
have now so it shows you that the
results of these conflicts really do
have effects do you have any other
questions i think we can take a couple
more maybe yep there you go
while you do um
another thing that the expansionists
would say to the anti-imperialists who
are saying how can we take someone
else's country from them the
expansionists would say more eloquently
than i'm about to well we took this
country from the native americans i mean
they were blatant about it well we took
this one what's the difference go ahead
massachusetts governor john davis long
was secretary of the navy
and he and roosevelt had a very testy
relationship roosevelt was his
undersecretary correct can you say
something about
that conflict because one was an
imperialist one was not long enough not
being that it's in here
yeah well and then also what happened
to what extent did roosevelt set us on a
collision course with japan ah
very interesting well these are two very
very big questions so first of all john
d long had been governor of
massachusetts and was secretary of the
navy
when theodore roosevelt became assistant
secretary
well
roosevelt was not good at being
assistant anything he was so dynamic he
was really a compulsive activist even in
his physical behavior not just in his uh
political policies uh so
one day
uh when secretary long was feeling ill
he had a series of body aches he'd heard
about a new
electric massage machine
he went off and spent the day being
testing this new machine
during that day theodore roosevelt
arrived at the office and realized he
was alone so he called henry cavett
lodge his best friend and said let's
start sending telegrams
and sure enough he started he authorized
unlimited recruiting of new semen he
ordered all american ships to be loaded
with coal and ready to sail and then he
ordered the pacific fleet which was in
anchored off china to make sale towards
the philippines get ready to sail he
wired admiral dewey so the next day
secretary long
came in and wrote in his diary i find
that theodore roosevelt has created more
of a ruckus than the explosion of the
maine created
nonetheless neither he nor president
mckinley
retracted any of those orders and that
set america on this path
so even from that position he was very
influential today
assistant secretary of the navy is not
such a big job but it was a huge job
then because the navy really was our
connection to the whole rest of the
world now as for japan uh this is not a
topic i cover in this book but it is the
subject of this spectacular book called
the imperial cruise
by
the same guy who wrote flags of our
father so flags of our fathers was about
his father dying on iwo jima then he
wrote this next book
this is james bradley i'm talking about
about why were we even fighting japan
and he traced it back to an amazing
episode in which theodore roosevelt as
president
essentially decided that although all
asians were barbarians the japanese were
not they were the aryans of asia
and should be allowed to rule asia and
have a
asian monroe doctrine and he sent his
secretary of war over there on a secret
mission disguised as a kind of fun
cruise in which he sent his daughter and
a bunch of congressmen along to
negotiate a secret treaty with the
japanese it had to be secret because the
u.s congress is supposed to uh ratify
treaties they never ratified this one it
was never made public and the first
thing that the japanese did after being
told by roosevelt
you're our conquerors is they conquered
korea and the koreans then quickly wrote
to roosevelt saying we've just been
conquered by japan you're our protector
please help and roosevelt wrote back
since you're now under japanese
occupation any complaints you have
should be addressed to tokyo not to me
so roosevelt did set us on the path that
led us to japanese militarism and
ultimately
the attacks at pearl harbor and the
episode of iwo jima
any more questions and how many do we
have time for i just uh
what would you have we have one more
well actually we did perfectly then okay
one more yes yes yes one more i'm not
sure this is a question before
before you started speaking i was
reading in the nation
and which is now 152 years old toward a
new foreign policy and the first article
by patrick lawrence whom i don't know is
called from destiny to purpose so
destiny comes from on high purpose is
down here on the earth
and mostly we have as a country
preferred destiny and he is arguing
against exceptionalism
which i think is
the most important argument to have
but i'm wondering and this this is kind
of a stupid question
um
our new so-called president
talks about america first which sounds
as if he's against intervention
is there any connection there oh that's
a whole world war ii
i think that our new president reflects
our divided national soul yes he's
anti-interventionist yes he's also
interventionist
so
in our national collective consciousness
these two impulses come out in different
proportions according to different
situations
um
i have no more idea than any of you as
to what direction we're going to be
going in in our foreign policy uh i find
the fact that there's a
moderate panic in washington over the
direction of some of our foreign policy
quite encouraging i wish there would be
more panic
but i do have some fears so i'm all for
changing the direction of american
foreign policy including in some very
profound ways
but this is a very delicate process you
can't do it with a tweet
world diplomacy is a very delicate
edifice you take one toothpick out and
everything else begins to shake so these
changes in
american foreign policy uh are delicate
the more radical they are the more
carefully they have to be thought
through so i find some of the messages
coming out of washington encouraging the
messengers are very disconcerting
there's no
coherence to the policy we're hearing i
hear for example uh let's not be caught
up in our stereotypes about russia let's
look new at russia and ask is it russia
really a threat to any of our vital
interests i think that's great but why
not apply the same policy to other
countries why not look fresh at our
relations with
cuba with iran or israel or saudi arabia
or pakistan i don't see that kind of
coherence
so
the debate
that this book talks about is still
shaking washington and i'll just
conclude with this one story authors
tend to like their books to come out in
the autumn it's called in the fall list
in publishing language you want your
book on the fall list because most books
are bought for christmas gifts and
that's said to be the best time now my
book didn't make it onto the fall list
but the publisher told me don't this is
of course a year and a half ago he said
don't worry i think that this is a book
that doesn't need to be on the fall list
because there's going to be a new
president and this book might turn out
to be more relevant than you think and
that certainly turned out to be the case
thank you all thank you robin stephen
[Applause]
thank you
book tv tapes hundreds of author
programs